- I'm here to show my boyfriend
what a bloody pad looks like.
(light music)
I've had my period for about eleven years,
and that's roughly 2600
used menstrual products
that I've had in my lifetime.
- [Interviewer] And how
many do you estimate
Steven has seen?
- Steve has seen maybe six,
if I did a good job of hiding them.
- My knowledge of women's
ovulation is pretty,
I would consider it average for men.
- Whenever I'm on my period I
definitely go in another room.
In terms of the bloody side of things,
I try to hide it from
him most of the time.
I think it's just been
ingrained in my system that
it's an embarrassing
thing to have your period.
- I mean I grew up with one sister,
but my sister was pretty good at
kind of hiding that part of her.
- I think I'm probably more embarrassed
for him to see it than he's gonna be.
(light music)
So this is a pad from sort
of the end of my period,
so I'd say it's a little
bit of a lighter flow.
Then I show it?
Alright.
- Alright, here we go.
- Enjoy.
(laughs)
- Alright, this is it?
- That's it, that's a light day.
- Oh, oh god, oh my,
just kidding, I'm kidding, come on.
- Really?
- Okay.
I mean.
- You've probably dissected worse.
- For some reason I was imagining
you were gonna hold up like a small Ziploc
like filled to the brim with blood
and I wouldn't even be able to,
I don't know why, I know
that's not even possible,
I mean maybe that's possible.
(light music)
So over the course of like
a period that you have,
if you're wearing a pad,
is this the normal amount?
- This is lighter.
- I keep turning it over
expecting to see something new.
So I was imagining, I was
imagining like blood red,
like what you imagine the
reddest of the red to be.
(light music)
- It's sad how, when
I first got my period,
how ashamed I was feeling about it
because guys used to give me shit for
tampons and pads that didn't
even have blood on them,
like I would have to like
subtly hide it in my shirt
when I went to the bathroom.
I just think that's like so weird when,
it's such a natural
thing that we go through.
I'm very relieved that Steve's
handled it so maturely.
- What I learned through this
actually had less to
do with the pad itself
than learning what your thoughts
were, like going into it,
that you have been more uncomfortable
than I even realized.
- I would say that I'm relieved
that Steve has seen it up close.
I think there's a way
to be still respectful
and not wanting to see this.
If you're dating somebody
and you accidentally
have a period that gets a stain somewhere,
I think there's a way to be nice about it
and still be kind of squeamish.
- What if I just vomited on the table?
That would've been.
- That would be so awkward.
- We would've had a lot
of therapy to get through.
(light music)